[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK KUBIK: We're
going to take you
along a little bit
of our journey today,
of getting to the cloud
and building applications
in the cloud at Global
Payments, and how
we're using Looker and
BigQuery to scale up
around the world for an
application that we've built.
Just a little background--
Global Payments, a
large payment processor,
headquartered in Atlanta,
Georgia, $4 billion
in net revenue last year.
If you don't know much about
us, about 2.5 million customers
that we've given some
sort of payment solution
to around the world.
And about 11,000 employees,
is the size of our company.
We have a strategy
at Global Payments.
It's about software
driven, partnered solutions
around the world.
An Omni channel
experience, you've
seen that in some of the
presentations around here--
we want to make sure that
we can deliver things
across multiple channels
around the world
and get into faster
growth markets.
One of the ways that we're
going to expand those markets
is going to the cloud.
Probably about a couple of years
ago, our Chief Product Officer,
Frank Young, had a mission.
He wanted to create a best in
class engagement platform--
not a BI platform, not
just a reporting platform,
but something that attracted
customers, created stickiness,
and was something that we could
be proud of at Global Payments.
So he partnered with us.
And about that same
time, our CIO Guido Saki,
put us on a cloud first
strategy at Global Payments.
He knew that we needed to
have a multi cloud, cloud
first strategy to deliver
things around the world.
We had to have reduced
total cost of ownership.
We couldn't do things on prem.
You've heard that theory
many different places.
So, he launched us
on that strategy.
We needed to build the
technology solutions
that our customers would
like around the world.
We needed a platform that we
could innovate on and deliver
new products every year, every
quarter, to drive business.
And we needed to do it securely
and safely in the cloud.
You've heard a lot of things
about security in Google Cloud,
but those were really
the driving factors
that launched us on this
journey that we've been on.
I don't know where all of
you are in your journey,
so I'll review a little bit.
This is a couple of years ago.
We started to take a look
at different vendors,
different things.
We enlisted the help of our
Architecture Department,
led by Ali Fawaz, to look
at some of these factors
to help us out.
Probably you guys had these same
factors, but I'll review them.
We needed not just a BI tool--
everybody seems to have
one, two, three of them.
BI tools network for
the mass markets.
We needed something
that could provide
embedded BI in that engagement
platform we're talking about.
We needed RESTful API enables.
Everybody out here is probably
trying to produce APIs,
trying to get out there where
people can code to your API,
rather than us have to
code for them out there.
We needed something that
was responsive design.
Everybody in here has
a different device,
a different mode of connecting.
We needed to make
sure that platform
was able to be
displayed on any device,
visually appealing to anybody
that wanted to do business
with Global Payments.
We needed a powerful
abstraction layer,
so that when we
changed data, that
changes very readily
out there, we
could put something in between.
That's where we used
the Looker platform.
And we'll get to
that later in there.
And we needed to
integrate with the cloud.
We have all evaluated many
different cloud vendors.
We chose a multiple cloud
strategy, we got that.
But for this application, we
chose Google Cloud Platform.
We needed something that
could power a data lake.
Data's King.
You got to have data to
do anything these days.
We evaluated things
on the technology now
and where we thought things
were going in the future.
You have to look
forward a little bit.
Things change very fast
out there every day.
The total cost of
ownership was a big factor
for how we wanted to produce
our applications in the cloud.
Security is number one.
We're a payment processor.
If we don't keep your
credit card number safe
and all your personal data
safe, we're out of business.
So we needed to use that
as a guiding principle.
And a data center region
availability-- everybody's
heard of GDPR.
India's put some
rules in lately,
to where you may have to
put your application locally
you may have put
your data locally.
So forward thinking,
this has allowed
us to take some of those
factors into account.
Why we chose Google Cloud
Platform and Looker out there--
again, GCP, Looker,
BigQuery and App Engine
are the main components.
Jason's going to walk
you through the design
and the pieces we used
to get to the platform
that we're rolling out.
We needed a customer
first design.
One of the things that
we learned over time
was you must listen
to the customer.
You've guys have all
probably heard it.
But we actually used My
Team plus some partners,
to build a prototype
almost, two years ago,
that we launched out
to the customers.
We got feedback back.
In January of '18, our design
team, led by Clare Bowden,
out of Ireland,
redesigned this thing,
listened to the customer.
In January of '18, we really
started building this out
for the customers.
We went to beta in the summer.
And we have been getting
feedback from the customers.
And I'll tell you where our
journey is gone to a little bit
later.
We needed API enabled.
Again, if we cannot enable
an API for our customers,
because we serve everybody
from the small mom and pop,
to the medium sized guy
with four franchises,
to the Verizons of the world.
So this architecture that
Jason is going to talk about,
services all of those customers.
Again, any device, anywhere.
And then we want to make
sure that we could launch
on an analytics platform--
Google BigQuery, and a lot
of the things that GCP,
that you're hearing around all
these sessions, could provide,
and we knew would
enhance our offering
to all of our customers.
Our custom built application
looks a little like this.
And I'll go into it
a little bit more
after Jason gives
you a little more
of the nuts and bolts
of the architecture.
But we need to scale
to any enterprise.
We need to scale
to-- your mom and dad
may have their small business,
it needs to be useful for them.
It needs to be useful for the
medium guy and the large guy.
It needs to be extensible
to any platform and highly
customizable, because it
has to be one-size-fits-all
for our users.
What I'd like to show
you now is, if you
could switch to demo one, is--
hold on.
This is where demo--
there we go.
Can you switch to the demo one?
There you go.
This is a little marketing video
that our team has put together,
the portal that we're launching.
Built on top of GCP,
with the components
that Jason's going to describe.
And I'll let him get up
here and talk about it.
But this is a portal designed
for everybody around the world
that we do business
with today, to get
the information about
the transactions we
process for them.
Looks pretty slick.
In my opinion, I
think our design team
has done a great job.
But I'll let Jason
tell you a little bit
about how we built that.
JASON DERLEIN:
Cool, thanks, Mark.
So like Mark said, we've kind
of went on this journey probably
about two years ago.
We started-- we
kind of got the--
we decided we're going to go
all-in on the cloud, which
is a pretty big change for us.
And can you guys
go back to slides?
There we go, we're good.
So I'm going to
talk a little bit
on what we actually built here.
So, obviously, it's a
modern web application.
It's designed
completely in React.
Everything's hosted in GCP.
We went with a
microservice architecture,
as everyone is doing nowadays.
And that gives us
some extensibility.
The application does
a lot of things.
But I think the most important
thing that we're here
to talk about today is how we're
getting this data from our data
lake to the customers.
And it's a little
nonconventional here,
but what we're
actually going with
is streaming this data
from BigQuery itself
to the customer in real time.
There's no reporting
layer in between.
We're not doing any
pre-aggregations
that you would typically see
with like a Lambda architecture
or something like that.
So, pretty standard
web application.
What I want to focus on
today is the reporting API,
which is how we're
actually getting this down.
As Mark alluded to, BigQuery
and Looker are our keys to that.
So let me start with what
our goals were for this.
So, we have some
disparate data sources.
Some things come in batch.
At the end the day, I'm
sure a lot of you have that.
We also have some stuff
that comes in real time.
So there's a challenge there.
You can't go with kind of like
a batch layer, where you process
it nightly, because we have
streaming data coming in
at the same time.
So obviously,
that's a challenge.
There's been
solutions to do that.
I don't know if you guys heard
of the Lambda architecture,
where you're take
your batch layer,
you'll take you're
streaming, and you'll kind of
amalgamate them in an API
layer and serve that up
to the customer.
That was one option.
The other thing we need to do
is, we want some self-service.
In previous lives
of this application,
we found ourselves having lots
and lots of different reports
that our team would have
to customize and design.
They're really just
permutations around other stuff.
So we would love to give some
self-service to the customer
and let them say I want this
column, I want that column.
And you'll see
where that comes in.
The third thing is, we
want it relatively fast.
This will-- you'll
see as we get in,
this is the biggest challenge
to this architecture,
going directly to BigQuery
is getting that speed
to web level, web speed.
And then, obviously,
fault tolerance--
when you're going through and
you're building a data lake,
you really don't want to--
you want to be able
to start from scratch.
You want to be able to
go back in and rebuild
the entire thing.
It's kind of the mindset
of the whole MapReduce.
You have the data
lake and you want
to be able to rebuild that from
scratch if your design changes,
say aggregates change,
anything like that.
I need to be able to go
back and start from scratch,
and not have, basically,
an immutable data
set at the end of the day.
So with those goals,
what we've ended up
building is a reporting
framework that kind of lives
on what we're calling a
multilayered data lake.
So, you can start with
the regular batch data,
comes in, files, we're
throwing all that
into GCP storage buckets.
From there, we move on--
we essentially move it
as is to BigQuery, one for one.
We're calling that
our trusted layer.
This is kind of our
Global Payments.
These are not industry
standard terms.
This is what internally we
are calling these layers.
So the trusted layer is
pretty much straight in from--
one for one, like for
like from the data set.
And then we'll go through and
we'll put some metadata on it.
We'll protect sensitive data.
We're not going
to persist things
that shouldn't be persisted.
At that point, we move
it to a second layer,
which is also in BigQuery.
So these are BigQuery
to BigQuery jobs.
And that's what we're
calling the transform layer.
So this is where we're going
to put some data quality
rules out.
We're going to go ahead
and normalize things
like dates, data types, get that
data in a clean state, where
you can put other
tools on top of it,
whether it be eventually AI
and MEL, that will come off
the transform layer.
This is our normalized
kind of data quality.
Now, I can always go back and
rebuild that from the bucket,
to the trusted, to
the transformed.
The key, I think, to this
design though is really,
we're working on the
consumption layer.
And this is kind of
equivalent to a batch
layer in a more traditional
big data architecture.
All the consumption layer--
I think of the
consumption layer almost
like a materialized view.
This is where we can take
multiple data sources that
came in from the
transform layer,
aggregate them together, flatten
them out, run metrics on it.
If we have some common
KPIs or any aggregations
that we want to run, we put
them in the consumption layer.
The problem is, then how do you
get that to the application?
I really don't want
all my applications
writing directly to BigQuery,
especially from the internet.
So this is where we have
our consumer system,
which, as you can see up
there, this is Looker.
And what we're using Looker
as is really that abstraction
layer to our data lake.
Got a little slide
here on Looker.
Looker's given us
all a lot of stuff.
Is anybody familiar with Looker?
If you're not, the platform
itself is really just--
it's its own modeling
language, really XML based,
where you can basically
define a contract,
and put the data
behind the scenes.
And Looker will go ahead and
form the query up and return
the data back to you.
This helped us a
lot, because when
we were building
this application,
we also came at it
from two prongs.
We were building the web
application, the reporting
layer, and the data
warehouse, the data lake, all
those layers, at the same time.
So what we did with
Looker is we basically
used Looker as a contract.
The model that we
defined in Looker,
we might have stubbed
some of it out.
Now the front end team,
who's building the APIs
can start coding against
that, while the back end ETL
teams are actually
fulfilling the data
sets behind the scenes.
And if we need to
change anything,
we change it at that one place.
That kind of gets to the
idea of the consistent,
no matter who's
looking into this data,
if it's going through
our Looker model,
everyone's going to get
it exactly the same.
Looker also offers an API, which
is key to this kind of design.
So, they have a very
robust API, where
I can do filtering, column
selection, things like that.
Anything that's in my
model, I can essentially
query through the API.
They almost have an
API first mentality.
So, I don't have to write
SQL for my code anymore.
I can use Looker just
like another data API.
It just happens to have
BigQuery behind the scenes.
Looker also gives
us visualizations.
So there are embedded
visualizations.
You see on the
screen right there,
you have the little
charts and graphs.
Those are all
driven from Looker,
from the exact same model
that we get the data from,
which is--
it really helps in the
development efforts.
I don't have to do
any extra development
to get a pie chart around the
same data that I already have.
I just basically configure
what called a Look.
I call that.
I can embed that
in my application.
You'll see that later.
Mark's going to show a
little bit more of the app.
Paging, that's another
thing where we do directly
in the Looker model.
So, some of this data is huge.
We're not going to
serve up through an API
10 million records coming back.
So I can actually get
paging, and Looker
takes care of doing the limits
for me, behind the scenes.
It's completely
abstracted from me.
I can just say, here's the
data I want, I want page six.
It'll tell me how
many come back.
The other key for us was export.
One of our requirements
is some of our customers
like to take this data
from the portal, put it
into their own
accounting system.
So rather than have to go
through and write an export
system to do this, there
is export functionalities
built in, in Looker we
essentially just proxy
them straight through.
So let me talk a little
bit about what we've built.
I might have to use the mouse
here to point to some of this.
So what we really did here
was, we built an API layer
on top of the Looker API.
We kind of extended
it a little bit.
It served a couple of purposes.
The first thing was, our
application is a SPA,
it's a react application.
It uses JWTs.
Obviously, I have
to have something
to convert that JWT into Looker.
So our custom API that
proxies over to Looker
is handling the
security from the JWT,
turning it into
the Looker model.
But the other thing
that we did that I
think is the key to this, is we
built a little metadata engine
on top of Looker.
So if you see the
API layer in here,
basically what
happens is just a--
find my mouse, there we go.
Can you guys see that?
OK.
So our app is really just
HTML5 react, piled down,
put in a storage bucket, load
balanced through cloud load
balancing.
Boom, there's your
HTML5 web application.
All the magic happens
here in the API layer.
So pretty much the
java script from here
is making Ajax calls directly
to the various microservices.
The one we really
care about here
is the reporting API right here.
So what this guy does is,
we've persisted the metadata
around the Looker
model into Cloud SQL.
So this guy can
actually go look up
all of the different available
columns in Cloud SQL for you.
Because I know who you
are from the token,
I can go say what queries,
what reports do you want.
And essentially, that's
just some custom storage
that we've done.
And then this guy just runs
a builder pattern and proxies
over whatever that request
was to the Looker API, which,
in turn, generates
the BigQuery SQL,
returns it back, proxies
it back to the front end,
into a standard JSON format.
This is really--
anybody familiar
with the open/closed principle?
What this has done, essentially,
has allowed us to extend this
with really writing no code.
I can build another
Looker model.
I can put it into our
configuration database.
That could point
to any data I want
and expose it through this
application, through this API,
with a configuration only.
I have to write the Look ML,
which is the abstraction layer.
Obviously, I have
to have the data.
But I don't have to
do any additional code
besides enabling it
in my metadata layer
for the customer to get it
or the portal to get it.
So now as we extend, and you
go from those 100 reports,
if I end up with a new request,
I can build a new Looker model.
I can put it into the app--
and the security is actually
put on the model layer.
So you might see a little
layer, the Report Builder,
which kind of gives us
some self-service as well.
So, we actually allow folks
to come in and customize what
they want this to look like.
So they can go into our
web API using the metadata,
and say, there's 700
columns available here,
I care about these six, and
I want to sort by these,
and I want to filter by these.
We'll persist that in Cloud SQL.
And essentially,
that just builds
a-- it's a builder pattern.
It's just a straight
proxy to Looker.
So as long as we have
the Looker model,
I don't even want to know how
many permutations we could get,
but it's flexible.
We provide some out
of the box stuff,
but the customer can actually
take the out of the box,
they can modify it,
they can save it.
They can share it
with their co-workers,
they can share it
with other people.
And that's all facilitated
from the reporting layer.
The other big thing
that I think we
need to talk about here is-
the title of the session
is how we scale this.
Everything in here is
completely scalable through GCP.
So the API layers all live
in an App Engine right now.
We may move that to GKE.
That seems like the
logical progression.
When we started this,
that wasn't a thing.
Looker is actually-- we're
not hosted by Looker.
We're self-hosting Looker
inside auto scale VMs.
So we can expand that
out as much as we want.
And obviously,
BigQuery is BigQuery.
You can do as much as
you want with that.
There's a couple of
pricing models on it.
There's fixed cost and
then there's pay as you go.
We're on a fixed cost for that.
Is there anything else?
Security.
So, one of the challenges too
that we really needed to do
is, the goal here
is have one API.
And based upon your token,
I only return your data.
So we have all of
the data in here.
The personas that use this
application are everything
from that single
merchant, who might have
one location, to maybe
a regional manager that
has 100 locations, to maybe
our own internal customer
support people, that service
the entire portfolio.
So we really wanted to ensure
that the security trimming was
done in the data layer.
So what we're actually
doing is, as we provision
users in this application,
we're using the Cloud Pub/Sub
and we're actually pushing
the data access ID.
So it's just location IDs.
We call them merchant
IDs, but think of it
like individual locations.
And we push them to BigQuery.
And in Looker itself, we join
to the table [INAUDIBLE] is
to the point where it can
handle someone having 200,000--
a customer support person might
have access to 200,000-300,000
locations.
We actually security trim
that right in the layer.
So when you pass over
the Looker query,
you're only getting back your
data, which is fantastic.
We don't have to manage
that at the API layer.
We keep track of it,
we Pub/Sub it out,
and we persist it to BigQuery.
And we do a join on the
data to right there get
the constraints, which is--
I don't know if anybody's
ever experienced--
that's a huge problem solved.
BigQuery's been a
lifesaver for that.
Most of our relational
systems could not
handle joining on
something that big.
So Mark talked about
the Omni channel.
Another key to this is we're
just looking at the [INAUDIBLE]
portal, the
application we built,
as really just the
first consumer of this.
This reporting
API that we built,
we could stick Apigee in front
of this, given it an API key,
throw it to a developer,
and the developer
can get the same access
to the exact same data.
You don't have to
play the scripts game.
Everything is going through
a single channel, which
guarantees that you're getting
the same beta, no matter what,
from a single source.
And I kind of alluded
to the performance--
you can probably expect
that that's probably
the biggest-- we've solved
most of the other challenges
on our design goals.
The two to three seconds
that you saw earlier
was kind of what our product
team wanted to strive to.
That's the biggest
challenge in this,
but we've come a long way.
So when we started this, what?
18 months ago, roughly.
Since then, last year,
they announced some custom
partitioning for BigQuery.
We've applied that.
So putting in partitioning,
lowering the set of data
that you're actually
querying against
has improved time significantly.
And we've actually implied
that on every single call.
So every single
model that we have
has a primary date that we have
set in BigQuery as the date
partition.
And we require the API calls
to pass in some kind of range.
I can't let you go through
the whole data set.
So I think the max you can
go back is maybe two years.
It is a filter.
You can say I can take seven
days, 30 days, yesterday,
specific date.
But we have to
constrain the data set.
So you're not looking at the
whole lifetime of the data
model.
The other thing that we've
been experimenting with
and has been--
I think is going to have
some huge progress, is
nested repeated.
I talked about we have different
disparate data sources.
Well, some of those
kind of fit together
in kind of a
hierarchical pattern.
You have this concept of a batch
when you're doing credit cards.
Inside that, there may
be multiple transactions.
Well, nested repeated
is a great way--
instead of doing a
traditional RDBS join,
you can actually put
those transactions
as a column inside BigQuery,
as another nested table.
And there's an un-nest feature,
which Looker speaks very well,
and it's lightning quick.
So we're migrating and we're
experimenting a little bit
with moving our consumption
layer a little bit more
to nested repeated and see if
we can get some performance
improvements.
So far, it looks
really promising.
The last thing that I'll just
mention is wide and flat.
The less joins you
have to do, the wider--
it's columnar, so I
think most of our models
are around 600 to 800 columns.
And we're exposing all of
those in our consumption layer,
where we've aggregated the
different data sets together.
We go flat, and
wide, and disparate.
That's fine.
Leave them null.
You only get what you ask
for back from BigQuery.
So if you're only asking
for these eight columns,
you're only going
to go through that--
the data set's only going
to peruse eight columns.
You can have that
as wide as you want.
I'm sure there's
a physical limit,
but I don't think
we've reached it.
That helps when you're
looking at performance.
Like, you can do these
aggregations on the fly,
you can join them together.
But what we found is
by flattening that
out the consumption layer,
and having our Looker model
point to the
flattened table, you
get much better improvement.
OK, so here's some
real world examples.
This is just from
partitioning properly.
You know, we started
out, these are
five different kind of reports
that we've enabled through,
that everyone gets.
You can see in here, two
x is the worst we did.
Just from partitioning,
some of them got to 10x.
You can kind of see a
correlation between data
processed and time.
This is the key.
First, I think, is
always apply a partition
in every query you're
doing, especially
if you're going to expose
this out in real time.
I'm hoping the nested repeated
can get these even further.
And we're probably averaging
in the five second range
right now.
To think about it, it's
still pretty impressive,
when you're perusing
an entire petabyte data
lake in real time.
I think that's all I got.
Mark's going to show you some
actual slides of the app.
Thank you.
MARK KUBIK: Thanks, JD.
So while we're talking about
that, what I want to go over
is a little bit of the app.
Because like I said, we
started on this journey.
We've been on it for
quite a few months
with some partners
and my internal team,
building this app.
This is what it looks like.
One of the keys, like JD said,
this is the look and feel.
Those top visualizations
come out of that model.
They come out of BigQuery.
All we can get--
seven, 10, 30 days,
two years with a
data out of there,
come through that API layer.
The cool part about that too is,
I may have different business
partners.
I have a bank in
Canada that just
wants me to send them a
visualization from our data
lake.
People don't want a report,
don't want things like that.
Other people just
want an API, and they
want us to give them the data.
If I want to settle and I'm a
developer, I want to get that.
So when they log
into the portal,
they'll see their data here.
If they have their developer
develop against our API book
that we're putting
out there, they're
going to get the same data.
If I ship this visualization
off to another portal
and let somebody put it in
their portal and display it,
it is the same data.
Because BigQuery and that
architecture that JD has shown
you allow you to do that.
The reason I showed you
the demo earlier is,
we're starting to roll this.
This portal is reality
and is going out.
These are the reports.
We found that a
lot of the reports
you make, and JD alluded to it,
how many people build systems
where you built a report, and
that guy needs this column,
the other guy needs
a different column,
and all of a sudden you end
up with just a ton of reports.
Because BigQuery allows us
to put all those columns out
there, allows us to get that,
this is the set of reports
that we have for a worldwide
audience right now.
And we're rolling it out.
It's not the hundred
permutations you used to have.
What we've found here is,
those visualizations, again,
come through the Looker
API from BigQuery.
We've built a custom
report tab down here.
And this, I think, is part
of a pretty cool design.
Some of our partners and
some of our design team
came up with some of this.
Those columns down there,
those come from the same API.
They've been delivered.
And that what you can do is--
I talked about before, we
have to service everybody
from the small mom and
pop to the big guy.
This little custom
report thing here
is kind of what I would call
the iPhone of reporting.
It allows you to take on,
and remove, add, sort,
any of the columns
on that report.
So when we hit that API
and get all the data,
we're grabbing all the data.
It's there.
It's instantaneous.
So I can put and remove things
from this portal as we go.
And that way, I don't have to
make 200 versions of a report.
It's all sitting
there, all coming
through that same
architecture from one database
in the background--
pretty cool, I think.
So, here's the fun part.
I showed you the
marketing video,
because this is
rolling out today.
We have gone-- we have
gone to pilot in the UK
and we have a worldwide rollout
strategy over the next three
months.
Kind of interesting
that we're here.
It's like, we're rolling
out, and we're here on stage,
talking, so that's kind of fun.
But what we got is we got
a multi region migration.
We've started to
consolidate applications
across the enterprise.
And we actually, Hadoop--
some people think it's
new, we think it's old.
We've actually retiring
our Hadoop infrastructure
that our finance
folks were working on.
We have started to consolidate.
With performance of BigQuery
and the GCP platform,
kind of had that kind of
any tool mentality too.
We've been able to put different
tools up against this--
Looker, other BI tools
that we have in-house.
Let's face it, we all have them.
You all might have
Tableau, MicroStrategy,
Business Objects.
They're loose against
this platform.
And we're allowing
people to use them.
We've let our data
scientists get in there.
We actually, with the
backing of our CIO,
did a few ML projects this year.
We went against the same data,
using some of the products
that GCP Google has out there,
typical ones, the easy ones--
attrition models.
You do attrition modeling around
the world against the same data
that's out there for
the portal that's coming
through the APIs, all of those.
Our internal customers have
found it very, very useful,
because now--
it used to be the data within
all these different systems.
Now, you've got
this thing called
BigQuery that in that data lake
that I can dump it all into.
That don't always
have to come and ask
for that one extra
column or this.
Data storage, as we all know,
in the cloud is pretty cheap.
We store everything.
That's the premise
of the data lake.
So now nobody's looking
for that additional column.
When we need that additional
column, like we showed you
on a report, it's there.
Because the technology
architecture
that JD talked about works.
It's going live for us.
And some of the external
applications that are out
there, we will be able to,
as we get that book of APIs
launched through
Apigee, we'll be
able to allow to give
people that book of APIs
and let them hit
the thing directly.
Here's our rollout plan.
Like I said, we're
scaling up to the world.
Here's the title of
the presentation.
We've been through UAT.
We have our regions
around the world.
We really talk
about four regions--
US, UK, Canada, and the AP.
We're rolling out our plan and
we're doing our load testing.
We'll have 10,000 users on this
April, rolling to 25 in May.
We'll have a full
$40,000 on by June.
And as we go through
the year, and we
migrate our other
divisions on there,
and see the adoption
come forward,
we anticipate having the
full 100,000 to 120,000 users
on this platform, hopefully
by the end of the year.
The reason we think
that-- and I'm just
kind of pulling this out,
I've anonymized this-- but,
like I said, our design
team has done a great job.
My team has done a great
job delivering this.
Our partners have done a
great job working with us
to get this out here.
But these are a
few of the reviews.
In our old portals, we
designed them for us.
They worked, but this
is the first time when
I've look at this-- and we
get people that have actually
looked at this
thing, and says, you
know what, from
different personas,
different levels of
the organization,
this is exactly what I want.
I can find the
information I need.
I don't have to wait for it.
You can see some
of the comments,
the customer reports
really, really useful.
People have claim they've
taken 20 minute jobs down
to a minute.
But, I just think it's the
technology, the design,
and the things that
Google, Looker,
and other partners around
here-- there's more of them--
have brought to bear
that allow us to deliver
this for our customers.
So, honestly, you can
tell, I'm excited.
It's going to be fun to roll
this out over the next year.
My team, it's been challenging.
We've learned a lot.
It's not a smooth road.
There's a few bumps and
we've learned a lot.
And you learn a lot.
Things change, but
it can be done.
And really, that was
our story for today,
is that it's out there, it's
going out, and it does work.
But that is really--
I was going to do
a demo, but I see
I'm running a little
short on time there.
These are the partnerships that
we've worked with from here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]